you know we feel like you do everything
with authenticity now Hannah has to
navigate a relationship with a teenage
stepdaughter you have teenagers at home
do you feel the frustrations
I have amazing teenagers
um yes I do I feel I feel the moments
where she was biting her tongue and
where she is just
praying for serenity now
um that being said again I close with I
have amazing teenagers yes how many
times do you hear mom you're so extra I
mean I think I live my children live
feeling that way they don't they can
tattoo it I mean there's nothing they
don't they don't even need to say it it
is fact your husband that's not who you
think he is why are you making him sound
like some sort of criminal mastermind
I may not know why your father did what
he did but I know who he is he lied to
me and then he disappeared and I want to
know the truth well first things first
welcome back to television thank you you
and Reese are executive producing
together so why was you know this what
you wanted to come back for and I want
to see you guys on screen together well
that's an easy one because it's a yes
for me so okay Miss producer Rhys you
just find us a little something
um and why this that's easy too I read
the book with my middle child and we
just completely bedtime went out the
window until it was finished we were
compelled to keep reading it's so
propulsive the read because
the stakes could not be higher they are
turned on a dime again and again and
again and in the middle of it is this
very Tender Love Story between
um a woman and her stepdaughter and kind
of the idea of becoming a parent so if
you mush all of that together and forget
it I mean I just don't know what could
be more exciting out of you what more
you could ask out of a role Laura's over
here like yeah
but see seriously when you get the the
news that Reese Witherspoon and Jennifer
Garner are going to turn your novel into
a television series what is that moment
like I mean I'm not sure I'm over that
moment yet so
um it's a dream come true and you know
very early on Jen and I had this
conversation about Hannah being the
grown-up in the room and I truly believe
that no one could go from being the
grown-up in the room to the hero of this
story except for this woman there yeah
in this show Jennifer you know Hannah
basically kind of turns herself into a
spy you know trying to figure out what's
going on not unlike you know you did an
alias I wonder how Sydney and Hannah
would look if they teamed up together do
you ever think about that one they would
be unstoppable Hannah would think that
she had nothing in common with Sydney
and then she would realize that she can
be just as Nimble think on her feet turn
things on a dime and just um take
matters into her own hands just like
Sydney bristowford by the way okay I spy
with my little eye a Victor Garber
reunion in this was it just did you call
him up and just say hey I need you to be
in this with me lucky for me our
showrunner um brilliant Josh singer
um happens to be a major theater geek
and you know Victor is a huge Broadway
Star first and foremost so Josh and I
conspired and we talked about how could
we get Victor in here what role would it
be right for him and it just worked out
perfectly that we were able to have
Victor and the only problem with that
was that when Victor was on set because
you know he he really thinks he's my dad
I mean I speak to him every Sunday spoke
to him yesterday
um every single Sunday of the world it's
just I check in like you check in with
your parents eating your vegetables are
you yeah yeah I mean half the time I'm
taking care of him but half the time
he's taking care of me and
um yeah so the only problem was I kept
smiling at him oh and I kept like
breaking character and just looking at
him like this because I'm just so proud
of it is it like no time his pet I mean
you said you guys are just friends so I
mean yeah you don't have to see it but
you all live it yes we we very much live
it we very much part of my chosen family
for sure and as if no time had passed it
really reinforced for me the idea that
we should work with the same people
again and again and again because
um there is it's like you just start
that much further down the field because
you already have just this comfort and
Trust built in and that was really
exciting for me Laura I noticed that
there were there were some different
things in the in the you know in the
series than in the book and you wrote a
few episodes so when you're adapting
your book for the screen number one how
hard is that to do and number two what
do you decide or what do you think like
okay I'm gonna change this or I'm Gonna
Leave This out or I think this is really
important I would suspect that has to be
hard for the author itself you know I
think that when I was writing the book I
started writing it all the way back in
2011 and I threw out 70 000 words of it
sometime around 2016. so I was very used
to throwing things away and killing my
darling and then this wonderful woman
here when she came on board one of my
favorite parts of this whole experience
was we got to sit in the backyard with
Josh and go through the scripts again
and again and as Hannah and Jen sort of
merged into one right
um it became obvious what belonged there
and what didn't you know and how we were
going to best serve turning up the
volume on this and making it as
propulsive and human and haunting as
possible I
comes from the book but the way it left
I thought
I got I have questions I need to know
what's happening you know five years
later there's stuff going on yes you
feel that too yes I do well what I will
say is this which is it's a little
Easter egg about about about the show
which is that the way we always imagined
it was that the show was a call and an
answer and the very first line of the
show is Hannah saying Bailey and the
very last line is the answer to that
call and so I think of it as a complete
story onto itself that said okay now
that I get to imagine Jen in my head
whenever I think of Hannah
I I should be so lucky see I see okay so
that was a Never Say Never door is open
that's what I took from that I don't
know
we are we are we both heard it and I
think there are cameras involved
but yeah there's nothing in in the plans
right now well if it means anything I
sat down to watch one episode I'm like
I'm gonna go talk to these ladies let me
sit down and watch the episode I watched
every single one of them six hours later
I looked up like what happened where
have I been what's going on it's so good
oh that makes sense congratulations how
about in gallery rice can we just could
you love her anymore I mean could you
really is it even possible I was like
she's so good because I want to jump
through this TV screen at her and she's
so I mean seriously but she's so good
and like so layered and I will say she
said she got a lot of that from you and
watching you and watching your example
and just how you move on set and she did
say she was sad she had to be mean
well
for telling me that she seemed way too
comfortable with it but seriously she
did she said I felt like you know I just
we just kind of fell into each other
yeah yeah I really love her yeah well I
just I really I thank you so much and
I'm so thrilled I think the thing is the
the more you watch the more thrilling it
gets yes and so I really just hope
people you know it is one of those
things the episode ends and you're like
well okay press play because I need to
know you can't leave me like that so it
is it's really good congratulations and
welcome back again we miss you thank you
[Music]